hello everyone and welcome to a game you
guys started requesting as soon as it
finished and for good reasons it is
former world uh champion vishwanathan
island versus magnus carlsen in the uh
blitz section of the norway chess it's
um quite a beauty you guys will enjoy it
it's been almost 10 years since since
magnus
took the title away from anand in in
2013 uh but uh now in 2022 the games are
still as crazy as ever even though anand
retired from classical chess he is still
allowing us to enjoy uh his moves in
blitz games so let's dive straight into
it uh anand has the white pieces and he
opens with e4 and magnus plays g6 he
goes for the modern defense or the robot
defense
we have d for d6 and now knight to c3
now interestingly bobby fischer in his
uh
famous book my 60 memorable games when
uh
annotating his game against paul benko
uh says that h4 is it would be a great
attempt here but uh he played knights to
c3 against benko and so does anand here
against magnus so bishop to g7 we have
bishop to e3 and now a6 but now after a6
anand doesn't go for the standard queen
to d2 uh he follows fisher's advice but
only a couple of moves later and he
strikes with h4 uh we have knight to f6
by magnus adding um
more pressure to this h5 square we have
f3 defending the e4 pawn and now queen
to d2 so the standard uh sorry b5 by
magnus and now queen to d2 so the idea
is a standard one like you would have
maybe against um a dragon or or a super
hyper accelerated dragon where you would
just go g4 h5 and bishop h6 trade over
the bishops and start some sort of a
counter
some sort of an attack with an open h
file so here h5 magnus of course will
not allow this and now knight to h3 and
here
magnus could continue just developing uh
but he decides to give up this bishop
for a knight bishop captures an h3 uh
they say that knights are a little bit
better in blitz than bishops uh so
let's see how magnus does uh with with
the knights rook captures on h3 knight b
to d7 and here we have castles queen
side by anand and now there are a couple
of
games that reach this position uh even
between some very very strong players
for example uh
aleko had this against the yanni pondish
in beijing uh in uh some 10 years ago in
2013 i believe um uh where uh liquid
defeated nepal and nepali knight beat
the knight d to b6 and here we have
queen to c8 by magnus and it is now as
of move 10 that we have a completely new
game uh so let's see how anand continues
so of course c5 is coming the c file
will open up so he goes for the
prophylactic king to b1 we have c5
uh d captures knight captures and now
knight to e2 anand remaneuvers the
knight over to d4 we have castles by
magnus and only now bishop to h6
preparing uh
to trade off the the bishops uh a5 by
magnus he wants to get those pawns all
the way and start opening up uh files
towards the white king bishop captures
and g7 king captures and now rook to g3
uh getting the rook to a nice nice g
file uh b4 by magnus and now knight to
d4 now you always have to be careful uh
knight to f check uh knight to a5 check
would be very unpleasant but here magnus
just plays knight c captures on e4 he
gives up a little bit of material to
grab a little bit of material basically
he will win the rook and two pawns uh
for the for the two knights so of course
anand has to accept there's no other way
f captures we have knight captures on e4
and now queen to e3 knight captures on
g3 queen captures on g3 and now as you
see uh magnus is up two pawns but anand
has a bishop and uh a knight for a rook
so a magnus goes straight uh for a queen
trade queen to g4 and uh if anan doesn't
want to trade he has to defend the rook
on d1 so queen back to e1 he says my
chances are greater with queen still on
the board and rook eight to c8 now it
makes sense to double up rooks and the c
file and go after the white king so g3
we have rook to c5 and now bishop to e2
chasing away carlson's queen queen to e4
and now queen to d2
and while you could go rook after c8
right away magnus says nope this is even
stronger rook to e5 we go
we put pressure on the bishop and also
queen to e3
will will come so here at bishop to f3
we need to make some room for the queen
uh queen to e3 uh offering a queen trade
and anand again declines queen to g2 uh
and now uh well you could go rook to c8
uh magnus goes to a4 first he wants to
open up the lines of attack towards the
white king but the disallows on under
this very tricky idea of knight to c6
not just putting pressure on the rook
attacking the pawn here and also the
pawn on e7 is being pressured
and magnus goes rook to f5 super
interesting would be a3 but of course
this is a bliss game so you don't have
all the time in the world to calculate
everything i will just show it because
it's very enjoyable knight captures an
e5 so he gives back the exchange queen
captures threatens checkmate and now c4
now the queen covers the the b2 pawn b
captures on c3 alpaca and now b3 uh we
play c2 we have to give up the pawn to
open up this
diagonal queen captures on c2 and now
rook to c8 we bring the rook into the
attack but after the queen moves let's
say we offer a queen trade queen
captures on g3 we end up with this where
island would be up a bishop but magnus
would be up three pawns so yeah and also
he would kind of have the attack uh but
with with perfect play uh white white
will hold this so it's very interesting
but uh magnus decides to go for rook f5
he attacks the bishop here uh rook to d3
on and defends it and it's uh remarkable
that you can just uh uh you know leave
the back rank like this rook to d3
and uh i mean the the king is on b1 if
if one check comes it could be very
very unpleasant uh luckily you you can
just defend you can just bring the rook
back and this is exactly what happens
queenie one check rook d1 queen back to
e3 going for the bishop and anand plays
rook to d3
he says all right if queen to e1 uh we
go for a drawback threefold repetition
if you are up for this but magnus
declines this he plays queen to c5 he
says i still have some attacking chances
i just have to open up the position here
knight captures on e7 by anand and now
rook to e5 attacking the knight and
again uh going for this rook to e1
square so knights to d5 and now rook to
e1 with check but now anan plays bishop
to d1 he doesn't allow magnus to trade
off the rooks uh rook after e8 and now
queen to d2 uh and now uh it would be uh
well now it would be a great idea to
play a precise move because the position
is now completely winning for magnus but
it's a blitz game magnus missed the win
here luckily you will not so feel free
to pause the video and try to find the
winning idea magnus missed while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on finding the only
move that wins the game and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is queen the g1 that's the good stuff
and now once you see it of course you
believe it there is no defense against
the rook captures bishop once rook
captures the bishop queen will capture
and then we can just play the other rook
to e1 and it's game over we're gonna win
the white queen and that's it and
there's no way for you to
to to defend this king c1 is nothing
because you're gonna have to capture
with the queen uh so i mean we can even
show it if you guys if you guys like
rookie one and that's it uh white just
resigns but magnus misses this rook to g
a queen to g1 move he plays a3 he keeps
true to his plan to open up the queen
side and now anand just captures the
pawn on b4 and asks what what do you
have here
uh so trading would uh be
trading would be good for magnus but
magnus plays a rook eight to e4 he now
attacks the queen puts more pressure on
white's position uh but it doesn't
really matter anand just captures on c5
even better would be queen captures an
a3 but this is too difficult to
calculate with a little time on the
clock and magnus is really really low on
the clock swan and doesn't want to
just let him read because here after
rook captures on d1 check rook captures
on d1 queen captures on d5 of course if
rook captures then you just get
checkmated there's queen c3 check and
that's the problem now we cover d1
square and we are threatening to pick up
the queen so best would be to block with
the queen but now we just trade and we
have these three connected past pawns uh
white just wins this easily but okay
queen captures and c5 was played d
captures on c5 and now b captures on a3
and now what do you play here c4 attacks
the rook we have rook to d2 and not rook
to g1 magnus goes after the g3 pawn
knight c3 attacks the rook on e4 and
rook to e6 and the rook will be a very
important defender here as anand will
start pushing this a pawn so the rook
needs to be covering the a6 square so a4
we have rook captures on g3 by magnus
now knight to b5
we have rook to e4 and now pawn to c3
and here
magnus played rook captures on h4 and
this is not the way to play this uh
anand is much better here so it's not
easy to play this but with the g5 it's
still possible to play now if h captures
on g5 you just start pushing the h pawn
uh one thing you don't to do is move
this rook away from the e file because
you really need to have this rookie six
the a6 maneuver available but magnus
playbook captures on h4 and now anand
just pushed a5 and that's it there's no
playing this position anymore uh magnus
uh put the rook on h1 but uh
it's actually that his time ran out here
and uh
the the game just ended uh but it
doesn't matter what you play rook to h1
or even if you play rook to e4 uh
seemingly the best move that kind of
hopes to get back to help out with the
defense we still just push and now okay
you can play rook to e8 but now knight
c7 attacks the rook and also covers the
a8 square with tempo and now after you
move the rook just a7 there's no there's
just no move here for uh for for magnus
h4 a8 queen you have to give up the rook
and now you have two pieces uh for uh
for nothing and that's just uh of course
completely winning for for anand uh but
yeah um carlsen's time ran out and he
was in this position that uh island won
the game so very nicely done uh coming
out of uh coming out of retirement to
enjoy some uh rapid and blitz events and
taking down the reigning world champion
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and congratulations to
everyone who spotted that winning idea
that was missed in the game i would like
to thank first eldon lord nagarjuna
ponogoti congrats harry three grants
andre theron and alexander john juarez
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the norway
chess
until it ends so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day